in the previous video we saw how with
your training examples backed up
horizontally in the matrix X you can
derive a vectorized implementation of
for propagation through in your network
let's give a bit more justification for
why the equations we wrote down is a
correct implementation of vectorizing
across multiple examples so let's go
through part of the propagation
calculation for a few examples let's say
that for the first training example you
end up computing this X 1 plus b1 and
then for the second training example you
end up computing this X 2 plus b1 and
then for the third training example the
end of computing this 3 plus e1 so just
to simplify the explanation on this
slide I'm going to ignore B so let's
just say you know for the to simplify
this justification a little bit that B
is equal to 0 so the argument going to
lay out will you know work with just a
little bit of a change even when B is
nonzero it does just simplify the
description on this slide of it now w1
is going to be some matrix right so I
have some number of rows in this matrix
so if you look at this calculation x1
what you have is that W 1 times X 1 did
use some column vector which means draw
a light ball like this and similarly if
you look at this vector X 2 you have
that W 1 times X 2 gives some other
column vector R and that's you know
gives you this I guess z1 2 and finally
if you look at X 3 you have W 1 times
x3 gives you some third column vector
that is this z13 so now if you consider
the training set capital X which we form
by stacking together all of our training
examples so the matrix capital X is
formed by taking the vector X 1 and
stacking it vertically with X 2 and then
also X 3 this is if we have only three
training examples if you have more you
know the obeah will keep stacking
horizontally like that but if you now
take this matrix X and multiply it by W
then you end up with if you think about
how matrix multiplication works you end
up with the first column being these
same values that had drawn up there in
purple the second column will be those
same four values and the third column
will be those are orange values what
they turn out to be but of course this
is just equal to z1 one expressed as a
column vector followed by z1 to express
as a column vector followed by z1 me
also express as a column vector and this
is again featuring examples you have
more examples and dug in more columns
and so this is just our matrix capital
z1 so I hope this gives a justification
to why when we had previously W 1 times
X I equals Z 1 I when we're looking at
single training example the time when
you took the different training examples
and stack them up in different columns
then the corresponding result is that
you end up with disease also stat
different columns and I won't show but
you can convince yourself if you want
stats with Python broadcast
if you add back in these values of B the
values are still correct and what
actually ends up happening is you end up
with Python broadcasting you end up
adding bi individually to each of the
columns of this matrix so on this slide
I've only justified that V 1 equals W 1
X plus B 1 there's a correct
factorization of the first step of the
four steps we had on the previous slide
but it turns out that the similar
analysis allows you to show that the
other steps also work on using a very
similar logic where if you stack the
inputs and columns then after the
equation you get the corresponding
outputs also stacked up in columns
finally let's just recap everything we
talked about in this video the existence
your neural network we said that this is
what you need to do if you were to
implement for propagation one training
example at a time going from I equals 1
through m and we said let's stack up the
training examples in columns like so and
so each of these values V 1 a 1 Z 2 a 2
the stack of the corresponding columns
as follows so this example for a a 1 but
this is true for Z 1 a 1 z 2 na 2 then
when we showed on the previous slide was
that this line allows you to vectorize
this across all M examples at the same
time and it turns out with the sum of
usernames you can show that all of the
other lines are correct vectorization
or four of these lines of code and just
as a reminder because X is also equal to
a zero because you remember that the
input feature vector X was equal to a
zero so X I equals a zero i right then
does a certain symmetry to these
equations where this first equation can
also be written Z 1 equals
w1 a 0 plus B 1 and so you see that some
you know this pair of equations in this
pair of equations actually look very
similar but just of all of these
industries advanced by one so this kind
of shows that the different layers of a
neural network are you know roughly
doing the same thing or just doing the
same computation over and over and here
we have a two layer neural network where
we go to a much deeper neural network in
next week's videos you see that even
deeper in your networks are basically
taking these two steps and just doing
them even more times than you're seeing
here so that's how you can vectorize
your network across multiple training
examples mix was so far then using the
sigmoid function throughout that neural
network turns out that's actually not
the best choice um in the next video
let's delve a little bit further into
how you can use different what's called
activation functions of which the
sigmoid function is just one possible
choice